[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez le mange une arracheuse
rapidement votre gauche mais api qui
vous commencé à tousser ou voies
respiratoires se resserre vous sentez
votre gosse enflé vous avez la
difficulté à respirer vous tentez de
faire entrer de l'air dans vos poumons
mais c'est impossible
les battements de votre coeur s'accélère
vous vous agitez plan que c'était
s'installe c'est en soit les gens autour
de vous panique mais on revient pour
vous aidez votre avis que cette affiche
est capable de parler tour dit angoissé
il fut apeurés vous vivez un choc
anaphylactique
vous en êtes mort la seule chose qui
aurait pu vous sauver la vie
c'est l'adrénaline cette molécule qu'on
trouve dans les auto injecteur de type
epipen expérience que vous venez vivre
c'est le pire cauchemar de plusieurs
millions de personnes à travers le monde
qui souffrent d'allergies alimentaires
sévères
malheureusement en 2017 la probabilité
que ce cauchemar se concrétise était de
plus en plus grande
puis ce conclave c'est l'adrénaline
comme étant un médicament pénurie en
raison d'une forte augmentation de la
demande et cette pénurie pourrait se
reproduire à tout moment dans le futur
alors imaginez si c'était nous deux
jeunes scientifiques qui contribue à
prévenir une pénurie d'adrénaline et ce
en modifiant le vivant nous sommes deux
microbiologiste de 23h et membre de
l'équipe des jeunes de l'université
laval
on participe à l'une des plus grandes
compétitions scientifiques ou monde
nommé hayden cet événement d'envergure
regroupe plus de 340 équipes provenant
de partout dans le monde
pour notre part notre équipe est
composée d'étudiants au baccalauréat à
la maîtrise et au doctorat
on concilie vie personnelle travail
études ainsi que nos travaux d'envergure
en sciences dans le but de faire une
différence dans le monde à notre manière
non seulement dans notre laboratoire
mais également auprès du public
ainsi en réponse à la pénurie
d'adrénaline et d'encore la compétition
et jam on ne décide de mettre à profit
nos connaissances pour concevoir une
solution
puis c'est ce qu'on vous propose notre
projet adrena listes basées sur la
modification de la levure
communément utilisés dans la production
de pain ou de bière et ce pour produire
notre adrénaline pour cinq films
démarche scientifique nous allons
comparer à la confection d'un gâteau en
trois étapes la préparation et la
transmission d'informations la
transformation et la finition
la première étape c'est la préparation
et la transmission d'informations en
cuisine pour la confection d'un gâteau
faut d'abord sélectionner une recette
qui a été écrit dans un langage
compréhensible par un parti par exemple
en france et puis il faut regrouper tous
les ingrédients nécessaires pour la
confection de ce gâteau comme du sud
l'est et de la farine je comprends cette
recette les ingrédients et on remet le
toit un parti qui était choisi pour ses
outils et ses compétences appropriées en
sciences
ce serait plutôt la levure qui va jouer
le rôle de notre parti est lui fait elle
été choisie pour ses caractéristiques
uniques en comparaison avec la
pâtisserie de notre méthode scientifique
va utiliser une recette sous la forme de
l'adn vous avez peut-être déjà vu ce
double brennilis l'information y est
emmagasinée par l'agencement d'unités de
htc 2g qui fondent le langage code
l'ensemble du vivant
le langage biologique puisse langage
peut être utilisé pour former les
structures plus complexes que l'on
appelle des jeunes que seront le support
de l'information pour la création de
molécules nécessaires ou ivan comme
l'adrénaline chez l'humain d'une
combinaison jane qui permet la
production d'adrénaline
ainsi pourra permettre sa production
chez la levure
nous allons copier aux nains ces jeunes
dans un brin circulaire dgt adn que l'on
appelle un vecteur puissant vecteur pour
être lu et compris par d'autres
organismes que l'humain comme évidemment
la levure ainsi notre recette est un
vecteur alors que nos ingrédients sont
des nutriments tels les sucres et les
acides aminés kobe ni le vecteur est
l'instrument sont remis à l'éleveur
notre parti pour lui permettre de
produire des médicaments
la prochaine étape c'est la
transformation en cuisine le parti va
mélanger tous les ingrédients en suivant
la recette qui lui a été remise qui va
prendre la porte la mettre dans un bol
insérer le tout dans un four après un
certain temps de cuisson
le gâteau est prêt
par contre une allure assez grossière et
quelques un perfecto en sciences on se
rappelle qu'on a un autre le bureau qui
contient le vecteur permettant la
production d'adrénaline et que les
maintenant contact avec l'une primant
dans ce milieu liquide comme pour un
gâteau on va augmenter sa température ce
qui va lui permettre de se multiplier et
de graduellement produire l'adrénaline
dans le milieu par contre avec
accompagné de plusieurs impuretés entre
autres des débris titulaire qu'il faudra
retirer
c'est pourquoi la dernière étape c'est
la finition
en cuisine on va découper le gâter pour
qu il l allure de ferry puis on va faire
un glaçage à ajouter quelques
décorations
on obtient donc au final un gâteau
parfait les tables les finitions dans la
méthode scientifique se définit par leur
retrait de toutes les impuretés qui
accompagne l'adrénaline et ce par
plusieurs processus de purification
préliminaire ultime en ont introduit
indiqué dans une colonne que le plus
grande affinité pour l'adrénaline que
pour ses impuretés
ce qui permet de laisser passer des
impuretés et de recueillir notre
adrénaline purifier on obtient donc un
cuisine un gâteau parfait et de l'autre
côté notre adrénaline purifier et le
rappelons-nous un peu pourquoi on a fait
toute cette cuisine
en fait c'était pour vous décrire ma
démarche scientifique permettant la
production de l'adrénaline à partir d'un
levure et par le fait même vous avez pu
voir que la science peut sembler
complexe à première vue mais que c'est
possible la robe simple et attrayante
malheureusement comme scientifiques ont
grassement pas la science accessible
en fait on n'en parle pas assez et on
peut définitivement faire mieux
peut-être à la surprise de certains la
levure qu'on faisait des cris est un
organisme génétiquement modifié
un fameux ogm ces organismes sont
controversés qui ont leur porte souvent
une vision négatif les côtés par une
incompréhension des mécanismes
scientifique derrière l'émulation
génétique est tout simplement des
raisons qui peuvent nous pousser à
modifier lui vend on en oublie donc que
ce n'est pas nécessairement la nature
modifier des organismes et ses
utilisations néfaste pour la société qui
peuvent inquiéter
pour notre part nous idée pourrait
sauver des vies comme quoi ya également
beaucoup du bien qui peut ressortir des
ogm
de plus dans le cadre de nos travaux
nous les utilisons de manière
responsable et contrôlé
la modification du vivant comme outil au
service de l'humain comme notre projet a
drainé
il fait partie d'un domaine scientifique
qu'on appelle la biologie synthétique à
mi chemin entre la génétique et
l'ingénierie ces modifications du vivant
par la biologie synthétique sont des
pistes de solutions pour répondre à des
problématiques très complexes comme
l'abondance plastique dans les océans
l'absence de médicaments pour des
maladies incurables ou évidemment une
pénurie d'adrénaline alors quand à notre
solution pour prévenir une pénurie
d'accrocs nalinnes nous sommes en bonne
voie de réussir mais nous n'avons pas
tout à fait terminée tant le travail en
laboratoire
par contre ce serait une première à ma
connaissance personne n'a reporter avoir
réussi à produire de l'adrénaline en
incorporant des jeunes humain à un autre
organisme vivant de plus notre vie
pourrait devenir une méthode alternative
de production du médicament ce qui
augmenterait son approvisionnement
mondial et les travaux notre équipe ne
s'arrête pas qu'à cette pénurie
en effet à chaque année on s'attaque à
des nouveaux problèmes et on continue de
contribuer à la formation des
scientifiques de domaine et vous quels
problèmes aimeriez-vous réglé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]